[Música]
hola que tal bienvenidos una vez más a
canadá en las américas café la emisión
semanal del servicio de español de la
radio canadá internacional hoy bajo la
nieve como ustedes pueden ver en esas
imágenes todo el este de canadá incluido
quebec y también la provincia de ontario
han recibido una fuerte nevada en las
últimas horas que comenzó en la mañana
casi el mediodía del jueves y se va a
prolongar hasta la última hora de hoy
así pueden observar ustedes lo que es la
vida cotidiana de los habitantes la
mitad de estos poquito como se podrá
observar en alguna foto que vos mismo
sacaste hoy
diversidad leer eso era la noche que
todavía no había caído hoy en la mañana
se ha acumulado un poquito más
yo tomé unas imágenes que que vamos a
ver dentro de un rato donde se muestra
el pesar o el peso de la nieve
yo vine caminando y camino media hora
bajo la nieve y el problema es que es
como estar en la playa caminando en la
arena pero crucero con frío la cara el
calor que el sol pero que más por el
frío
pescar en el lago fue divertido
divertido hay que buscar la forma de
nosotros tenemos
román de un grupo familiar que tengo con
toda la familia argentina mandé imágenes
las imágenes que vamos a mostrar dentro
un rato y una de mis sobrinas que vive
acá deseado estoy contenta porque está
perfecto para esquiar y tiene razón para
la gente que le gusta esquiar es una
gracia como decíamos con pablo esta
mañana un colega de la sección en inglés
una vez me dijo una frase que me resultó
muy interesante porque uno tiene la
costumbre de vivir quejándose del
invierno y es verdad el invierno de este
país dura bastante el problema no es
invierno en sí mismo sino las
complicaciones que vienen con la nieve
con el hielo principalmente y este
colega te de 'harry me dijo una vez hay
que hacer las paces con el invierno
porque de hecho el invierno va a seguir
estando ahí y si uno vive aquí no va a
tener que vivir no va a tener que
sobrellevar todos los años así que hay
que hacer las paces con el invierno no
necesariamente amarlo ni mucho menos
pero aceptar que está ahí y que uno
tiene que convivir con el medio ambiente
que los rodea durante el inicio
totalmente
que a mí lo que me pone en la gente
hoy hacen 7 grados y no por ejemplo
mañana arriba hacen dos sobre cero
con esa gente la gente que de haber
sacado nieve durante todo el día de 30
grados
es más te sale por los poros más limpias
vamos a garante de todos los vamos a
reventar hemos hemos comenzado ya a
derecho no más con el tema que
pensábamos a abrir nuestro programa en
el día de hoy esto es canal en las
américas café la emisión semanal que les
traemos desde el servicio en español del
radio canadá internacional como ustedes
ya han podido ver y escuchar estamos
aquí en el estudio paloma martínez
leonardo gimeno
escribiendo mirando para contestar
saludos a todos sí señor y mi nombre es
luis laborda y tenemos una invitada en
el día de hoy que ustedes se encuentran
como es habitual allí en la otra punta
de la mesa ella es maría juliana
angarita bohórquez buenas tardes
muchas gracias por haberse día como hoy
desafiados los elementos y mariah apoyan
a viene hablando de él yo soy óseo de
museos de la memoria de colombia sí ya
vamos a desarrollar ese tema pero
hablando de elementos tú sabes que
durante la campaña libertadora allá por
los 1800
un temblor de tierra en caracas y
bolívar estaba ahí durante la guerra de
independencia
bolívar se subió en los escombros para
arengar a sus soldados y dijo y les dijo
si la naturaleza se opone nosotros la
venceremos entonces es una lección
leonardo para que yo tengo más cosas a
ayunar lo podemos ir viendo fotos que
tenemos sobre quiero decirle en su
cumpleaños que no tiene qué
[Aplausos]
[Música]
cerebral
un amor entonces alguien que cumple años
y que lo festeja con esa pasión el drive
liza que no lo voy a desafiar con un
asado
[Música]
es una buena manera para congelado para
terminar con este mal y no dominemos ya
es como decíamos tenemos algunas fotos
que gentilmente profesionalmente
abnegadamente produjo pablo gómez
barrios en el día de hoy unas fotos que
nos muestra sobre cómo se encontró a la
ciudad de peñas salió de su casa
con ese frío y con esa cantidad de nieve
que te encontraste en el barrio en el
que tú vives que es cual pablo es ese
hoy el hágame son net que es un barrio
del este de montreal ahí vemos yo no sé
qué sucedió pero venía una patrulla esta
mañana en esa esa calle que vemos ahí es
la callada esto ya es más cerca esto es
aquí en la esquina de la calle es en
catering y podría y podría este es en el
parque mesón nef
aparte de acá está cerca de casa así que
por ahí voy a caminar de vez en cuando
cuando me aburro del calor y voy a
visitar el invierno y no solamente no
solamente vos registraste imágenes de lo
que es el invierno en una ciudad como
montreal que por supuesto recibe nevadas
importantes como otras partes de la
provincia pero en el fuera la ciudad la
cosa puede ser más complicada
también el aventurero cumpleañero
leonardo gimeno registró imágenes en
este caso un vídeo donde se pueden ver
cómo se desenvuelven diversos habitantes
de esta ciudad y de sus alrededores cada
vez que caen centímetros y centímetros
de nieve que en esta ocasión se
calcularon en aproximadamente 50 si el
tema es que la gente sigue trabajando la
gente sigue siendo o sea por ejemplo hoy
por una cuestión de una condición
especial las escuelas de todo el área de
montreal y alrededores se cerraron pero
la gente sigue siendo trabajada
gente dentro de la ciudad sí señor cerca
de
[Música]
dijo oportuno en realidad
dónde está
el baile de congreso el palacio del
congreso
y hay buenos mostrando la esta mañana a
esa hora llevaba cerca de las nueve de
la mañana y las máquinas porque eso
también es parte del folklore canadiense
las demás hacen maternal canadienses y
que vayan a limpiar las calles porque
evidentemente la vida continúa fresca
pero continúa así que mostrando ahí un
poquito de qué se trata mi caminata de
todas las mañanas esas para la mecánica
son las que despejan las calles para que
puedan circular el tránsito vehicular
durante una tormenta como la que estamos
viviendo
ella es la gente de entrar los autos
contra esas palas es que arrojando a
niveles a los costados y se bloquean las
entradas y salidas de garajes justamente
la imagen que viene dentro de según
20minutos 92
la imagen que viene dentro de algunos
segundos muestra cómo queda un auto
aprisionado con la nieve apisonada
gracias al paso de las máquinas
topadoras ahí por ejemplo hay una
persona que está obviamente trabaja en
ese edificio y está limpiando la entrada
para que pueda la gente salir y entrar
al estacionamiento del edificio porque
con una valla de nieve de esas
características no se puede pasar
ese es un auto que quedó atrapado con
esa cortina o ese muro de nieve que la
topadora le arroja hacia el costado para
bueno en realidad para limpiar la calle
que todo
esa nieve esa nieve que esas máquinas
van empujando y que ponen así al lado de
estos carros es pesadísima está
compactada entonces cuando te vas a
sacar tocaron tienes que
esa nieve y ahí termina con dolores de
espalda y en canadá porque salen de esa
bruma y eso es nuestro compañero
leonardo avanzando en la nieve para
poder llegar a la última imagen es la
torre que casi no se ve por la cantidad
de la torre donde estamos en este
momento nosotros lo que yo quiero decir
es que no se ven tan impresionantes esas
imágenes o sea sí pero
pero como limpia tan rápido las calles y
los autos siguen circulando como si nada
parecería que no caerán bien pero acá y
cuando la acumulan es cuando podemos ver
las grandes montañas por varias regiones
de por varias zonas de la ciudad que las
van acumulando hay estacionamientos
enteros llenos de nieve y los dejan
libres justo para pilar la todo el
invierno entonces eso es muy particular
porque limpian rápidamente y luego
parece como si nada pasara pero si pasan
los largos y no tienen mensajes así es
el drone nos dice buenos dias tome hasta
dónde se los felicito amigos roberto
villarreal desde monterrey méjico ángela
viviana mendoza lizarazo nos dice
comparto tu gusto de hablar conmigo
prefiero mil veces el calor yo también
javier ortiz dice una tertulia por lo
que estamos haciendo es de momento y
gustavo look a uno de nuestros top fun
saludos de la ciudad de melo
departamento de cerro largo en uruguay
saludos a leonardo por cumpleaños muchas
gracias que le gustaba feliz día mundial
de la radio para el próximo jueves 13 de
febrero
marvin nos está viendo y tommy también
me saluda y un fuerte abrazo por el
cumpleaños gracias actores gente tome
castor bueno sobre el día mundo de radio
poco más tarde el pablo nos va a hacer
alguna referencia sea que él va a estar
a cargo de la transmisión especial del
programa especial que se va a emitir el
día jueves de la semana próxima al
respecto y ahora dejando ya de lado el
tema invernal y las quejas y lamentos
vamos a darle espacio a nuestra invitada
que como la presentamos hace unos
instantes se llama maría juliana
angarita bohórquez nos viene hablar del
museo de la memoria de colombia porque
varios para vos trabajaste en tu tesis
sobre este museo contanos antes que nada
de qué trata este museo el museo de
memoria de colombia fue creado por la
ley de víctimas y restitución de tierras
del 2011 es una ley que busca dar
respuesta a las necesidades de 8
millones de víctimas en el medio del
conflicto y ya con un proceso de
justicia transicional en marcha entonces
es un museo particular porque se crea en
medio del conflicto y durante las
negociaciones de paz tiene como objetivo
fortalecer la ley dice así fortalecer la
la memoria colectiva respecto a los
hechos de violencia de las décadas
pasadas y contribuir con medidas de
reparación simbólica para las víctimas y
además contribuir a que las cosas que
pasaron no se repitan es decir tiene una
función pedagógica y es un museo que no
existe físicamente por ahora pero tiene
casi más de 5 años de vida y ese fue el
tema que yo investigue todo ese proceso
de construcción social y el del guión
museológico previo
y en tu tesis hablaste de este museo y
no solamente en el museo sino de las
circunstancias que rodearon su creación
y su puesta en funcionamiento como por
ejemplo cuál es exacto fue una tarea muy
compleja pero también rigurosa porque
requería contextualizar un tema que
desde por si es complicado para los
colombianos en un contexto académico el
canadiense entonces
afrontes de este este obstáculo
proveyendo alimentos de contexto pero a
la vez que dieran cuenta de la
complejidad para los museólogos entonces
eso es un aspecto importante que que
abarque en el trabajo y es decir más
allá de los retos de crear un museo que
son enormes
este museo tenía retos adicionales un
contexto político y también muchas
expectativas de las víctimas sea era
bien importante contextualizar bien lo
que estaba en juego para él en el
trabajo de los museos la primera
exposición que se llevó a cabo fue voces
para transformar a colombia y voces
estamos sobre bueno de las voces de las
víctimas que es que cuentan sus
testimonios pero también las voces que
se necesitan para transformar a colombia
es decir la de todos los ciudadanos
entonces hay un trabajo de escucha de lo
que es difícil escuchar y difícil
nombrar entonces requería toda una
estrategia museográfica que permitiera
que la gente entrara abriera su mente
y que se cuestionario sobre cosas
realmente profundas que es cuál fue el
rol de cada ciudadano en la guerra
porque llegamos a lo que llegamos y qué
podemos hacer para cambiar entonces esas
voces son voces que hablan pero también
voces que esperamos que empiecen a
hablar y me decías antes de entrar al
estudio que esta propuesta generó
entredichos y posiciones contrapuestas
de diversos sectores de la sociedad
aclaramos que nos estamos refiriendo un
conflicto que se extendió por casi 50
años en colombia que divide hasta el día
de hoy a la sociedad colombiana hay
sectores que está a favor de una
posición y de la contraria esa otra
posición hay una cantidad enorme de
víctimas tanto ya sea de personas que
perdieron la vida durante este conflicto
como de aquella que quedaron con huellas
en su cuerpo o en sus familias por haber
perdido ellos a sus seres queridos
y el conflicto hoy en día cómo se
expresa o cómo se expresa en el caso
específico de este museo me decías que
incluso hay gente que está encargada de
dirigir lo que niega la existencia de
que haya habido un conflicto en colombia
si es un tema donde se materializa esa
lucha por definir qué nos pasó entonces
es apenas normal que con un gas con un
cambio del gobierno lleguen otras otras
formas de ver el conflicto y desafíen
las anteriores el problema es que acá
hay cosas que no se pueden controvertir
los hechos las las muertes los
desaparecidos y en la posición del
actual director del centro de memoria
histórica se acerca mucho a eso a negar
el conflicto como un conflicto con
orígenes políticos y socioeconómicos ya
catalogar lo más común a una amenaza
terrorista de un grupo de bandidos y
pues eso impide conocer exactamente las
dinámicas y ver la la continuidad de
violencia que va más allá del conflicto
que puede incluso retrasarse hasta la
conquista
entonces es un director que busca apoyar
su plan político y electoral desde su
partido y pues obviamente eso impacta
mucho la confianza que las personas y
las víctimas tienen frente a la
institución sobre todo víctimas de
crímenes de estado en una espera que
sean las que el museo primero busca para
siendo una instancia estatal es decir
deslegitimar su labor si no logra
generar confianza en las víctimas del
estado entonces eso es lo que está
pasando desde el principio que no
durante mucho tiempo no estuvo él
como tal ahora vemos imágenes ese museo
donde está en este momento emplazado
bueno las imágenes que vemos son de la
exposición voces para transformar a
colombia que fue una exposición temporal
itinerante que viajó por las ciudades y
que mostraba los grandes lineamientos
del guión museológico en el que
trabajaron los museólogos por más de
tres años y que es el fruto también de
todo este proceso del que hablaba de
construcción social no físicas sino
sociales en este tipo de museos lo más
importante es eso es generar confianza y
obviamente
una relación estable duradera que toma
tiempo entonces es algo innovador porque
se puso a prueba el guión de una forma
ustedes ven por ejemplo las estructuras
en madera muestra que está en
construcción y abiertamente dice este es
este guión esta está en proceso de
creación entonces es una exposición que
es en la que ese material el material
hizo el el museo antes de que exista un
edificio entonces yo me encargo de
documentar este proceso porque
justamente
fue efímero existe un museo tiene un
predio esta semana pusieron la segunda
primera piedra qué quiere decir esto ya
habían puesto la primera y el nuevo
gobierno quiere ponerla su primera
piedra es decir ya empiezan finalmente a
construir
se espera que se abra en el 2020
vamos a ver 2022
en 2020 en el 2022
y bueno me gustaría agregar de que que
nos pasó o sea pero más que lo que nos
pasó qué es lo que nos está pasando qué
es lo que está pasando en colombia
actualmente de que este es para la
memoria de conservar la memoria del
conflicto pero ese conflicto finalmente
no ha terminado todavía hay violencia en
colombia hay líderes sociales que están
siendo asesinados y que forman parte de
ese de las víctimas de ese es el
conflicto está teniendo una
transformación las las modalidades de
violencia son diferentes pero todas se
derivan de unas mismas dinámicas más
allá que se desmovilice en unos actores
surgen otros por diversas razones
geoestratégicas de colombia es una lucha
por recursos es una lucha por la tierra
y por el control de la tierra
y hasta que sus temas no se resuelvan el
conflicto va a seguir sobre todo si está
apoyado en raíces casi que culturales de
estigmatización en la diferencia de
descenso político que no se tramita por
el diálogo sino simplemente el rechazo
directo a todo lo que no sea igual a uno
entonces eso es lo que perpetúa el
conflicto se sigue viendo las
poblaciones están
pues desamparadas en la medida en que
están viendo asesinados sus líderes
sociales es como si asesinaron acá al
vecino que se encarga de ver que la
basura no está en el piso ya matan al
que está trabajando por las causas
comunes y eso pues creamos una
insatisfacción y una desconfianza con el
estado enorme implementaron con un
acuerdo de paz con con un gobierno que
es complicado yo quería mencionar maría
juliana que tú recibiste una beca por
haber escrito un ensayo relacionado con
tubo de tu trabajo de investigación y
con tu tesis de maestría y me llama la
atención que cuando te nombraron la
ganadora de esta de esta beca dijeron
que era por la originalidad del tema
me imagino que en una sociedad como ésta
que hablen de un tema como este la
creación de un museo de la memoria en
colombia llama la atención y claro que
es poco conocido finalmente es un
proceso que es poco conocido por eso es
original para la necesidad de dio la
abeja y en el campo de la museología en
general es la primera vez que un trabajo
sobre latinoamérica es reconocido en él
en este premio
y lo mereces tan sólo por el tema
inclusive yo hice una labor muy rigurosa
de traducirlo y justamente explicarlo en
un contexto canadiense y eso habla pues
del éxito demuestra el éxito del trabajo
pero
es un tema que va más allá de lo
académico y el premio es simplemente un
reconocimiento de ese trabajo
comprometido socialmente y aúna una
brillantes de los museólogos en el medio
de desafíos que son enormes y eso es
respetar a los residentes
y eso lo respeta la comunidad académica
por eso era tan importante documentarlo
porque sabíamos que iba a entrar por lo
menos yo sabía que el gobierno
eventualmente iba a cambiar es apenas
normal y este proceso necesitaba ser
documentado porque es una parte
importante y que es poco tangible y que
tanto con tanta apertura es decía parte
del premio la gente se interesó
realmente en el tema la gente sentiste
una sensibilidad particular
en los comentarios del jurado fueron muy
generosos tal vez de lo que más rescato
y siempre digo es que me pareció muy
importante escuchar que ellos decían nos
vimos reflejados nos vimos reflejados
porque logras demostrar la dimensión de
la responsabilidad de alguien que hace
una exposición que tiene una una función
social particular entonces a pesar de
que el digamos la tema del conflicto
armado sea desconocido
los desafíos terminan siendo muy
similares en este momento para los
museos desde que reprogramarse de
acuerdo a la realidad social entonces si
se interesaron se interesan cada vez más
y es mi labor también apoyar haciendo
eso hablando del tema
y mostrando el trabajo que se hace en
colombia y más allá del jurado de parte
del público veíamos en el vídeo que nos
hiciste llegar que hubo una concurrencia
bastante importante a la muestra
inaugural cuál ha sido la respuesta
hasta ahora y fue muy significativo
haber podido ir a hacer un trabajo de
campo no solo con el proceso de creación
sino luego cuando se concretizó porque
ahí es donde uno ve la importancia de
hacer bien las cosas hacerlas con un
rigor hubo más de 80 mil visitantes en
la en la muestra de bogotá que fue solo
dos semanas
en un momento en que era importante
hablar de lo que estaba pasando en
plenas elecciones y se sentía en el
ambiente que el sitio de la exposición
era un lugar donde la gente podía
empezar a hablar conocerse escucharse y
escuchar a las víctimas que estaban
presentes de todas partes del país
estaban ahí entonces en las imágenes que
vemos se muestra eso lo vivo que era ese
espacio y decía que se postergó la fecha
inicial de inauguración del 2020 al 2022
hay augurar en certeza al respecto hay
alguna inseguridad de que se vaya a
inaugurar cuando deba ser hecho
es un tema público lo cual en colombia
genera siempre dudas de la contratación
en colombia es complicada el predio
existe
el dinero de la cooperación
internacional existe
uno pensaría que el guión porque ya está
hecho lo van a usar esa es la parte que
se va a trabajar y depende de eso de qué
tan satisfecho esté el gobierno con ese
nuevo guión para que lo implementen los
recursos están faltan son los acuerdos
sociales que legitimen el el museo que
es lo más señor nos llama de
financiamiento internacional si yo
quería preguntarte ha habido también
financiamiento de parte del gobierno
no sobre todo desde la cooperación
internacional
el museo hace parte es la
responsabilidad de un centro de
investigación centro de memoria
histórica que es el que recibe unos
ciertos dineros del estado pero el
grueso del dinero viene de cooperación
internacional lo cual es a veces un tema
álgido cuando la comunidad internacional
empieza a cuestionar los las posiciones
políticas de los nuevos directores
porque obviamente va a entorpecer el
proceso pero a su vez es una ventaja
digamos porque hubiera habido
financiamiento público colombiano de
alguna manera eso también podría ser una
herramienta tengo para bloquear de
alguna forma inauguración del fallo
el proyecto está blindado por por varias
partes legalmente el acuerdo de paz le
ordena la comisión de la verdad que está
trabajando en este momento que muestra
sus resultados en el museo entonces ya
esa es una parte
y por otra parte la ley de víctimas va a
ser extendida en el tiempo porque pierde
vigencia pronto y eso también garantiza
eso está la presión internacional por
ejemplo esta semana el centro y el museo
fue expulsado de la de la coalición de
sitios de memorias del mundo es la es la
entidad que agrupa la mayor cantidad de
museos del mundo de memoria y entonces
la sociedad está la gente en colombia se
está dando cuenta de lo importante y de
lo de lo grave que es perder el
prestigio que se tenía con este proyecto
entonces yo creo que eso va a ayudar a
que el proyecto se lleve a cabo habrá
alguna implicación canadiense canadá
tiene inversiones en cuestiones sociales
y en cuestiones de derechos humanos a
través del mundo entero con muchos con
muchas agendas digamos específicas
hay algo de canadá en esta exposición
fue financiada en gran parte por el
gobierno de canadá
y canadá está sobre todo en temas de
desminado de sus armas que son no
tradicionales de claro
y eso es como el tema de especial en el
que se especializa la cooperación
internacional canadiense hay toda una
red de apoyo a este proyecto no solo
oficial sino de académicos canadienses
que comienzan a conocer más el tema y
que eso ayuda mucho de acuerdo y además
hemos ido específicamente
háblanos de ti de maría juliana sabemos
obviamente quieres colombiana al origen
si llegaste aquí me decías hace 8 años
llegué aquí hace casi 10 años a estudiar
y después emigre
ya permanentemente veces la maestría en
museología y ahora estoy haciendo un
doctorado en mediación patrimonio y
museología también en la universidad de
quebec ya que estas ya inmersa en la
sociedad no es nuevo
digamos ocho inviernos y me encanta me
comentaba que le gusta limpiar me gusta
porque no tengo carro entonces no tengo
que yo lo disfruto si tengo que caminar
camino
es muy lindo limpia empecé el día mi
cumpleaños primera vez es que me caí
y lo disfruté mucho así que quiero
seguir qué recuerdos tienes del columbia
estoy tan tan al tanto y como que vivo
en una realidad paralela y sinceramente
por mi investigación la mayoría de mi
familia está allá entonces recuerdos son
muy vivos y casi que un presente
continua más frecuentemente columna hace
dos años no voy voy a ir en septiembre
[Música]
si lo ideal es ir por lo menos una vez
al año
el tiempo y bueno cada vez que uno viaja
esto un proceso en un volver
y un largo sur y el mensaje si en
realidad etna maritz aparato no hice
extraordinario labor admirable es un
mensaje para maría juliana y después
bueno la gente sigue conectada y eso nos
alegra mucho y además de tu
involucración en este proyecto del museo
algún otro proyecto alguna otra
iniciativa alguna otra idea que ya
tengas en mente para concretar tengo
muchos proyectos los estudiantes de
postgrado acá tenemos que estar haciendo
muchas cosas del tiempo entonces soy
parte del comité de derechos humanos del
museo del holocausto trabajó en un
proyecto de investigación que está
basado en concordia y tiene un
laboratorio de curaduría en el que
hacemos exposiciones con temas similares
porque finalmente eso es como mi
especialización
no me puedo apartar de esos temas ya no
puedo darla
es apartar de ese dolor que una vez uno
ya lo conoce es muy difícil darle la
espalda pero entonces se ampliando
geográficamente es el tema
este proyecto de investigación es de
cuatro años con académicos de diferentes
universidades de la ciudad
multidisciplinar que busca conectar los
museos las comunidades y la academia
aparte es un montón de entre otros
proyectos aquí ya haya asistencia con
profesores mejor dicho haciendo una vida
académica con todo lo que eso conlleva
porque es de llegar a que haya hablaba
francés entonces por qué estudiar
maestría doctorado en francés
no me hago las cosas fáciles porque
escribí en inglés la maestría y ahora en
el doctorado ser en francés hablaba un
francés estándar internacional que
cuando uno llega acá no sirve entonces
después
argentina traen la maleta llena de
guantes que no sirve eso pasa siempre
con todas las lenguas precisamente las
lenguas que se enseñan son estándares e
internacionales
ninguna lengua y estándar internacional
es muy particular
pero no tuve la suerte de tener un
proceso de inmersión pues muy
privilegiado mi esposo es canadiense es
que entonces eso es más no le copio el
acento pero se lo entiendo
muchas gracias por haber estado hoy con
nosotros pedimos televisión pero
cerramos el tema porque tenemos poco
tiempo para interesar por estas trazas y
y ahora vamos a pedirle entonces a pablo
que nos presente el trabajo especial en
el que está trabajando precisamente con
vistas a un programa especial la semana
próxima así es es que el 13 de febrero
próximo el jueves 13 de febrero próximo
ccd se celebra el día mundial de la
radio que fue decretado así por la
unesco
y vamos con las radios asociadas no con
todas con tres radios asociadas de radio
canadá internacional que ese radio
rumanía suiza swiss info y
radio praga internacional vamos a hacer
un programa especial para digamos
conmemorar resaltar ese día mundial de
la radio
es el tema central de ese día particular
es el mismo tema que la unesco decidió
que es la diversidad entonces vamos a
hablar de la diversidad aquí en radio
canadá internacional que ya todos la
conocemos en qué consiste la diversidad
cuando tú tienes una emisora por ejemplo
como radio praga internacional que tiene
10 idiomas en su programación pues tú
ves ya de entrada que hay una diversidad
bastante amplia
en fin entonces es la idea de conmemorar
ese día vamos a animar la emisión en
español vas a coordinar la emisión en
español pero de hecho va a ver también
en misiones en lees en inglés
en chino y en nadie en las cinco lenguas
de radio canadá internacional bueno
perfecto eso va a ser entonces el jueves
y las semanas próximas salidas al aire
va a salir al aire el 13 bueno el
viernes
va a haber pues ese programa que va a
pasar como un
uno de los reportajes o entrevistas que
hacemos durante el día de trabajo y
bueno pues evidentemente por lo
pondremos también para el fin de semana
bueno perfecto entonces quedan todos
invitados a participar de ese misión
especial también y ahora paloma martínez
no va a explicar cómo funciona y de qué
se trata la aplicación móvil y bueno
ahora tengo que leonardo se cansó de
presentar la aplicación porque me fue
muy cómodo que cuando estaba haciendo la
parte técnica de visitas turcos se
acostumbró en nuestro sitio internet
pueden encontrar la manera de bajar a
sus teléfonos celulares nuestra
aplicación en las cinco lenguas de las
que difundimos en programación en radio
canadá internacional baja en la primero
en español y a partir de ahí pueden
acceder a todas las demás lenguas y
encuentran contenidos como ustedes saben
vídeo pero también escritos también en
fotografía encuentran mucha información
en los diferentes formatos en los que
presentamos nosotros nuestros reportajes
y nuestros artículos
hoy alentamos muy
a todos los que nos están escuchando en
este momento y que no han bajado la
aplicación que lo hagan plataformas más
populares en android y en apple pero
todos los enlaces directos a esas
tiendas para ir a bajar la aplicación no
se encuentran en nuestro sitio internet
a la derecha está la pequeña publicidad
de media de necesito ayuda de leonardo
www.uned.es se halla y van a encontrar
la información para dar bueno como
ocurre siempre o casi siempre muy
frecuentemente y prometemos leer
mensajes de nuestros oyentes pero no
tenemos tiempo para hacerlo porque nos
quedan escasos minutos y tenemos que
presentar los temas destacados y nos que
hemos estado trabajando a lo largo de la
semana
entonces le invito primero a paloma que
directamente su topo de esta semana de
todos los que has trabajado pues los que
les propones en primicia en 30 segundos
bueno un médico canadiense entre los
campeones del super bowl y se trata de
lohan duverne está de que es uno de los
jugadores del equipo ganador de kansas
city el que ganó este famoso premio
trofeo vince lombardi que es el trofeo
de super bowl el fin de semana pasado el
domingo pasado entonces loja di bernardo
berna
duverne está dueño de los chips de este
equipo tiene también una carrera como
médico entonces hizo mientras mientras
se estudiaba practicaba y se convirtió
en campeón entonces ahora es médico y
campeón
el reportaje que les presento hay toda
la historia de los grandes metas
nosotros teníamos un equipo de fútbol
también
man ag enfocada en una época tener un
número 4 es el orden son los años 80
el de nombre paredes y era doctor
también entonces el doctor para desear
la pelota
hasta arriba a la izquierda se veía al
médico canadiense si quieren conocer de
gigante
uno con jugo pero nunca se pierda y está
mírelo y nunca se piensa en un médico y
además en el primer médico en trabajar
en la national football league en la
liga nacional de fútbol americano y
maría juliana agregada cuando hablamos
de san lorenzo decía que se llevaron más
que a ti al revés
final de la libertadores
el impacto se llevó a piatti
muy rápidamente porque el tiempo apremia
en lo quiero invitar a escuchar una
entrevista que hice con la dramaturga
chileno canadiense que se llama carmen
aguirre
es una pieza de una obra de teatro que
se está presentando en este momento en
el marco de un festival de artes
escénicas en vancouver del 4 al 15 de
febrero se llama anywhere but here que
podríamos traducir como cualquier lugar
excepto aquí y que sucede en el muro que
separa a méxico de eeuu y en el que hay
personajes todos los actores y ocho de
los nueve actores son todos latinos y
era muy importante para ella para carmen
aguirre de los actores y actrices fuera
latinoamericanos entonces es un poco de
realismo mágico que hay en esta obra
donde personajes de distintas épocas se
encuentran en tiempo real en el muro y
hay intercambios entre ellos escuchen en
la entrevista con carmen aguirre para
que comprendan mejor la idea bueno muy
bien entonces ese es el tema que nos
propone pablo esta semana leonardo tu
habitual crónica de tecnología del caso
sobre la info demia
estas pandemias informáticas y no tiene
nada que ver con el virus informático
sino con el virus que generan las redes
sociales transportando información que
no corresponde o que no es verídica
entonces están en realidad desinformando
la soya en el caso basura basura exacto
basura de información en este caso con
respecto al coronavirus hay gente que lo
ha visto pasar por su facebook o
instagram o twitter el humo generado por
los petardos es capaz de acabar con ese
patógeno mentira los productos
encargados de china vienen con un
coronavirus en el transporte mentiras
una sopa de murciélago es mentira el
aceite de sésamo es capaz de acabar con
el virus en diversas superficies
mentiras vídeo de la sopa de murciélagos
en un hombre está comiendo un murciélago
el ala de el murciélago donde hay más el
muchacho es un youtuber un blogger y no
estaba estaba en pala o haciendo hace 10
años atrás haciendo una filmación para
el lugar no tiene nada que ver hace un
montón de mitos que circulan por la red
están sobre la extensión mi enfermedad
se ha generado una especie de locura en
torno al coronavirus que surge de verdad
en china lo discutimos la semana pasada
china tiene 1000 entre 1200 y 1500
millones no recordamos las cifras acá
hasta ahora hay quinientas personas o
500 víctimas de la enfermedad lo
lamentamos por ellos evidentemente pero
en 1500 millones de visitantes 500
personas víctimas de una enfermedad no
es considerado plaga ni en la epidemia
sea que el dato que él tenía también en
una de tus textos que yo lo usé para
reforzar esta idea el 99 por ciento de
los casos están circunscriptos a china
dicen así que es realmente un tema muy
brevemente pues nos queda ya menos
espacio aún una noticia en realidad que
publique esta semana una convocatoria en
la región del stri aquí una de las
regiones que componen la provincia de
québec que tiene disponible 1000
estos vacantes en el área de la salud
hay una convocatoria para enfermeras
auxiliares de enfermería gestores
monólogos etcétera tienen posibilidades
de trabajar en forma inmediata en la
región streets está abierta la
inscripción y va a estar abierta hasta
el 16 de febrero pero va a ver una
presentación y un reclutamiento que se
va a llevar a cabo el día 22 e incluso
las personas que no se hayan
preinscripto pueden participar ese día
22 para postular a uno de estos mil
puestos que ofrecen ventajas excelentes
e incluso incluso transporte y no nos
pregunten a nosotros por favor o sea
estamos dando las noticias pero vayan
directamente al respecto y nosotros no
hacemos más que difundir la información
bueno se nos acabó el tiempo vamos a
llegar a dos o tres horas por semana eso
sí
[Música]
gracias entonces nuevamente a maría
juliana andar y zamora
cumpleaños a leonardo gimeno y será
hasta la próxima
chao
[Música]